recording what's going on hey everybody
and welcome back this is honeywell
with your favorite sister sofia and
sistine you guys
it's the end of the year obviously you
know that if you're listening to this
and what are you ho ho hos doing this
year because christine and i
like to subtly call everyone hoes yeah
if you're listening to this you're our
ho ho host but
i i honestly when i before i came into
this i
was trying to think of something
christmas and witty and that was the
first thing that popped in my mind i was
like maybe that would work
yeah did it work it didn't land i'm not
gonna lie let me know if it landed
let me know if you use it on your family
members tell me how they react i'm sure
you guys can all agree with us
think the freaking lord 2020
is over oh my god i really have a strong
feeling that there's no way it could get
worse
from here so it's only uphill no
there's no way i'm jinxing the world
right now but i just feel like 20 21
there's no way it can be as bad as 20
20. we're going uphill i hope so yeah
high hopes it's kind of sad because i
feel like this whole year we've been
just going in motion like christmas
for us right now if you're gonna listen
to this it's after but christmas is
tomorrow
yeah for us wow crazy how the year has
gone by do you still feel like
even though many many many opportunities
that you were hoping for didn't happen
as a lot of people can relate do you
feel like you still accompli
accomplish some things like this year
yeah yeah
oh hell yeah like what our podcast
i really think we did pretty well and a
lot of the times that we were super
hesitant about starting it and
we went for it and there's amazing
opportunities that are coming 2021 that
69 will be excited to
tell you guys about but i think for both
of us and i
i think for speaking for both of us
we've really grown this year
yeah i feel like i'm i've matured a lot
yeah
i think we kind of know more of what we
want i think in terms of our love life
yeah
it's as you guys know it was a bit of a
rough patch for a hot second
but i think that we kind of dove head
first and just really went at everything
but we didn't have to say normally we
kind of like question things
i think as well we're always in a
relationship
so being single and also being forced
to stay in your home so it's not like
you can distract yourself
yeah i think that that was sort of the
best thing at the same time too
which is easy because we're able to
motivate each other even though i was
freaking miserable the whole time so sad
i think
stories we had stories they have the
content oh wait
we should probably mention uh apologies
there will be no video this week
um we shot something you guys are still
trying to figure it out
we're really bad at this we're trying to
figure out how to film from home
and we don't know how to link audio and
video
and also make us look decent if it's not
on zoom we're figuring it out i promise
we'll get it
you know if you hate it and where you're
kind of annoyed that there's nobody this
time so see i will just post a video of
the fight we mentioned last week of us
wrestling i don't know if you guys
remember that
yes that can be a replacement we'll put
that with the audio in the background
we'll give you guys a little christmas
present that'll be our present um
i actually was thinking about this the
other day i know everyone
and their families have some sort of
holiday traditions
that they like to do and we don't
necessarily have
a routine tradition that's that's
on brand with christmas we have one one
tradition
we normally throw an xmas party every
single year
yeah this is the first year we haven't
done it since we were
babies i am so happy how happy
low-key sorry mom if you're listening to
this but we're so happy there's no party
this year
i am actually normally i don't love
christmas and that sounds super weird to
say
yeah what um because if you don't like
christmas i think you're just considered
a bad person
i think you're about to um yeah i am the
scrooge uh
you are but the fact that the fact that
it's so
relaxed this year and even with the
gift-giving it's relaxed
and there's no stress of having you know
people over and
i agree with that you know there's a
couple of things that we do
every single year that kind of is not on
brand for christmas
but we normally get really fit
before all these christmas parties and
it's not intentional like i love
yeah i love the christmas parties i do
think they're really funny like having a
couple
spiked eggnogs and then flirting with
whoever's single at the party normally
it's always
some older people so it's not really
like it's
hanging out with each other slim
pickings out there but we end up working
out a ton
yeah okay let's narrow it down to three
things yeah we do three things
unintentionally every single year jinx
you owe me hot chocolate
if i know i'll try to make it thank you
um
first as you said is working out i
sometimes feel like subconsciously
we are getting really fit and exercising
and eating healthy because we just want
to start a new year on a good
with a good head start so you can kind
of get that new year's goal
going right two we always
watch love island towards this end of
the year i don't know what it is
it came out we've been watching it since
it came out and
this is the thing is when love island if
you guys don't know what it is it's a
now has a us version but it's a uk
love fest in a mansion people trying to
pair off
reality show and cece and i we were in
london
at the time the show launched and this
is before it was on hulu and it started
becoming way
popular in the us but from that moment
every single year we watch it
and we re-watch it addictive addictive i
don't we
love the characters if molly but don't
you know laura came on
oh my god molly may and more higgins if
you guys are listening
if they ever listen yeah i doubt it but
if you are for some miracle we love you
there's something about love island at
the end of the year that just gets me
feeling you know excited and warm inside
maybe because you were offered a
position on the love island us
you guys this is true yeah
still considering if i joined a dating
company i don't think us as good as uk
because the banter the guys the the
whole situation we said we would go on
the uk version if it was not filmed
and the pickings were perfect oh 100
okay what's the third thing the last
thing we do every single year and it
becomes an
accidental tradition and we just figured
it works i notice all of our traditions
are just
very accidental they're always
accessible is
hamburgers christmas night every single
year
i think it was because everything is
closed normally and there are
very very very few restaurants open and
it's normally places that have
hamburgers
and so we always order like 15
hamburgers
so each of us honestly have like two i
know and it's funny because i'm sure
normal people have a nice lovely
christmas dinner
we're eating like nasty nasty ass songs
yeah but it's so
good and i i have to say last year was
so
annoying our neighbor our neighbor
stole 15 hamburgers from us
you guys and he is the only person
living in that house
he refused to give it back do you think
he ate 15 hamburgers
like what do you do with 15. what do you
do with 15 hamburgers
have a hamburger competition with
yourself to see how like the
timing just christmas day just scarfing
them down
unless they taste like the krusty krab
you know whatever it is
jokes aren't landing that's okay that's
okay i'll let it slide it's the holiday
spirit
you know what i realized actually just
now what
perhaps the reason i don't love
christmas
is because you ruined it for me i ruined
it for you yeah
i ruined it for you so why are you
laughing huh that sounds like
i don't even remember no i don't i
haven't done anything to you let's just
say you
crushed my holiday spirits oh my god
what did it
you took a big fat dump on my holiday
spirit oh my god
that i like the reason i thought i
actually took a dump on
was like i've never done that she's like
that i can't oh
my god it was like that you what have i
done are the one
that told me santa isn't real
you guys you guys first of all
i will have to tell you no no no let me
explain
i was too young to figure this out
really at least wait till i'm like 14.
you know is that too old okay maybe like
12. 12 is accepted when did i tell you
what grade i think i was like
nine or eight i was
shattered and the best part is sophia
said it's so nonchalantly because this
is how i found out
it's christmas eve i'm in my jammies i'm
too excited to sleep i don't even
remember this i
remember it was yesterday i'm too
excited to sleep i go into my mom's
bedroom it's nighttime just
trying to you know fall asleep again
whatever i see sophia walk out of her
room
with my mom because they're assuming i'm
in bed
carrying all of the presents downstairs
and especially the ones that are labeled
from santa
and i go what are you guys doing it was
like 12 o'clock and i was like what are
you guys doing and she goes
you do realize santa isn't real right
and i go
yeah obviously i knew that let me help
and i was oh i'm sorry i went back to
bed
wait that's so sad i'm not getting that
christmas the next day i was like
fraud fraud everything's alive wait
did i really quickly i'm so sorry
can i tell you guys how i found out
santa wasn't real
i'm one of these people i'm like an
investigator i always
try to figure out someone's life so
with my research i told my mom that i
wanted a bell
right off of santa's sleigh you did
what a specific because i saw the polar
express and i think that's what happens
in the movie and so i was like
that's that's going to be a task i'd
like to pause you right there what
child asks for like a bell it was a trap
that was the whole point because i know
if i ask for a
teddy bear she can get it easily ask for
a sleigh bell
now that's that's hard so this is so i
i try to challenge my mom and if she
didn't
follow through with it standing isn't
real she does
so i wake up on christmas morning and
there's a bell
and it says from my sleigh ride i got
your letter blah blah blah i am
elated santa is real honestly when she
came through that bell i thought
no way this dude there's no way
all that stuff i'll just say a week
later
i'm running around with my bell i'm
holding it everywhere i go it's like my
lucky bell i'm telling everyone at
school
weeks later it was like when school came
back i went into the cabinet
or some drawer i remember what it was
and there it was
a plastic box with all the bells in it
and all i did was just i look at my bell
on my hand
i match it to the other bells and i walk
over to my mom and she's sitting in her
office i go
santa's not real
she was so mad at me she's like you
ruined everything
i'm sorry i really love christmas for
you but i also ruined it for myself and
you also ruined the tooth fairy but
that's the story for another that's
enough
i'll tell you about that later um i have
very special treat for y'all today
what is it i have brought in a
conspiracy theory
but not just any run-of-the-mill
conspiracy
a christmas conspiracy i think
honestly this might be one of my
favorite ones be i picked it out
knowing that this is so up your alley
really
you will love this more than i will love
this i am so excited
okay here we go is everyone the grinch
of christmas
is bringing in a christmas conspiracy
theory your jokes are
really hit in this yeah okay
okay this is it here we go
are you listening yes okay now i am
thank you
i knew it i knew i had to check in god
you know i always just think about porn
conspiracy
sophia has major selective hearing you
guys
like i know my mom this quick story time
really
oh god when sofia was a teenager
she she wouldn't
listen to you if you called her name or
you asked her to do something she would
just pretend like she didn't hear it
even though we're in the same room
so sophia would go i swear mom because
my mom would freak out y'all even my dad
was like sophia why
i really didn't hear it my parents you
you convinced them you said it's my
hearing i
i can't hear you i think there's
something wrong with my hearing
they take sophia to the doctor they run
all of these yeah for hours for hours
and the doctor comes out to my mom and
goes
yeah it's just selective hearing i got
grounded my phone was taken away my
computer was taken away because he's
like
there is he's like huge problems fully
just ignoring you
ignoring you she doesn't want to listen
and from then on out now i actually so
that is why i checked in
so sometimes do that here is the
conspiracy
so santa in the santa claus
which is a movie so santa in the santa
claus
is actually an exiled wizard from harry
potter
what's that look at okay ready to say
that again
so santa santa in the santa claus movie
is actually an
exiled wizard from harry potter let me
get into it
this is the theory that santa is an alum
of hogwarts
we all know santa is magical right
yes but the evidence does stack up to
this theory how does santa get up and
down the chimney sophia
ever thought about that yeah his powers
he has powers
have you ever seen the videos of him it
was a hypothetical question do not
answer
i have this i have how does he get up
and down the chimneys
blue powder power if you didn't know
what
flu powder is powder in harry potter
it's that
green [ __ ] that they throw and it's like
it's like green smoke flu powder
and why can't we see him sophia why
don't tell me the blanket over yourself
oh invisibility cloak
okay you know what that's that can't be
true everyone that watch i love harry
potter
big fan big fan i have another one how
do you think
he gets to every house in one night and
a sleigh with
rudolph maybe a time turner no now
you're making him seem way less
fun and adventurous magical hold on
you're telling me right now santa being
a wizard makes him
less fun and less magical
i think being a wizard defeats no
because it now
it sounds like he went to school with
dumbledore me
is think about it dumbledore
think about it that could be a
possibility they kind of look this way
i have a feeling that hogwarts has been
there for a long time
so maybe it was before a double door
wait wait
this can't make sense you know why
because
am i thinking too large sophia turn off
whenever i give a conspiracy
you get so logical it is full because
it's the hogwarts isn't real at the
school
and then santa is a student an alum
are you saying that jk rowling
no what i'm saying is jk rowling is
santa boom
i don't know what i'm saying i actually
like that one oh thank you
oh some of your thoughts on that to be
honest that
that was way too much to unpack that was
a little bit of like a i feel like you
just short circuited it i did
i hate giving theories to you because it
gets so logical
around before i think jk rowling don't
get too technical about it okay
so santa is an alum of hogwarts
yes graduating class of santa is harry
potter
okay yep santa is harry potter we'll
move on from this
that's okay i hope you guys enjoyed it
more than sophia i did not like that one
my brain goes like haywire dammit um we
have also a little special treat
um sophia and i are gonna bring on just
for a quick second
my mom and our little sister scarlett
and what question do we ask them again
we asked them about
their lessons that they learned in 2020
and then what they look forward to
in 2021 and some advice um they gave
really sweet answers and so we're really
excited to
let you know what they said so stay
[Music]
tuned
[Applause]
okay you guys we're doing an episode
with with you very soon yeah okay
um but we wanna just give them a little
sneak preview of you
so one thing that you've learned in 2020
we'll do that first
health is wealth and um actually staying
healthy
you know when things like this happen
it's really important that we all
make sure we are up to date on
everything from vaccines
and you know keeping our bodies healthy
and our minds healthy that's really
really important so
these pandemics happen we're ready to go
we're ready to go
ready to go health as well that you hope
for 2021
i hope we all get through this
and get vaccinated so i want to rephrase
that something
you're hoping for 2021 not a wee oh okay
i just i just want to have a good
night's rest actually full eight hours
would be amazing i know you don't sleep
we gotta get to the bottom
i just worry too much she's worries
about every single one of our
well-beings
and so she just doesn't sleep she'll
wake up in the morning she goes i got a
bit too
nice red and then i got and got coffee
and then i read more
it's really hard so i'm always thinking
about everybody so i just want to sleep
in 2021 isn't that right right now
that's a great answer perfect all right
thanks for coming on
yeah we love you i love you i love you
oh that's funny okay while we're waiting
for scarlett
to get ready for you guys i guess we'll
give our answers yeah let's do that
um what i learned in 2020 was
just to bite the bullet and go for what
you want no matter what the
circumstances i think that
we all have things we want to do and
when we aren't being
we're not allowed to do it or we can't
do it it gets us kind of in this rhythm
and this groundhog day so
um i really learned to be inspired by um
my surroundings and by you and since we
launched the show
it's been really incredible you guys
like we've had amazing opportunities
that are coming up in 2021 so just go
for it oh okay
and also i learned to never get
invisalign
um i'm an idiot and i have crooked teeth
on this bottom row and for some reason
since quarantine i've been just looking
at myself in the mirror way too much
because i have the time
and so i figured that they look horrible
even though no one notices them
so i got it didn't realize um how much
of a time commitment they are now i had
these little dots scraping my gums and
currently
um i'm going to go to the dentist to get
them removed but
2021 what i want to do is obviously stay
healthy
and um keep in contact with all my
friends i really think that
maintaining relationships with everyone
is really important but to also
once again really go for it like
hard-hitting
we have one life and sistine i are gonna
take over 2021.
yeah yeah you don't know what's coming
heck yeah that's a good answer thank you
oh gosh let me think about mine um okay
what
i learned from 2020 is i feel like i
stood up for myself
more than i ever have i was always shy
and afraid to speak my mind if someone
would tell me off
i would almost apologize to them and now
i was like you know what no
and i said what i wanted and i was
better at saying no to people
yeah and because they did it to me so
i'm proud of myself i definitely want to
carry that into 2021
not let people walk all over you nope
2021 i
i think i would like to um
work harder and procrastinate less
because sometimes i let the idea of hard
work
scare me and into not even trying it at
all
so sort of just you know breaking down
that barrier and forcing yourself to do
it because at the end of the day
work at least for me it's fun and i
enjoy doing it when i'm in the
when i'm in the grunt of it yeah but you
know
taking that first step to try to pursue
something is scary so i just want to
you know force myself off that ledge i
think a lot of people have that problem
is that doing anything that they're
really excited to do but also
there's a huge risk of failure yeah of
course it scares you
and i think it's i think for us
especially we've had to learn that a lot
this year yeah
and especially with our last guest we
had alana pratt on and we talked a lot
about
how you know just go for it and it
doesn't really matter
if you fail or or it doesn't work out
who gives a [ __ ]
you're young give one life try
everything this is what i would say
anytime you're about to go into a very
daunting
situation or something that just gives
you a little bit of stress
ask yourself this one question what's
the worst that can happen
that's true what is the worst
psychonauts what's the worst that can
happen
okay you send that text to a boy and he
doesn't answer yeah
okay yeah
all right you go for your dreams you
fail i guarantee you
another door will open at least you went
for something that you want
you ate that extra piece of pizza who
cares who cares don't
live with regret go for it do it
we've been in lockdown this whole 2020
so get
at it baby sister scarlett here to give
her
20 20 and 20 21. do i go back there
um you know what make an entrance
however you feel fit
go for it come on in scarlet come on and
take a seat over here
oh am i going up there yes come on
around come on around
here you go hey hey
what's up whoa how do you feel your
second appearance on the unwaxed podcast
i feel really uncomfortable you can sit
next to me
yeah yeah so this has been we need to
get a bench there we go so
scarlett what have you learned in 2020
and then the part two of the question is
what are you going to do in 2021 um
i guess that i just really hope to go
back to school
go back to college and then go to
college and actually not
do it over a computer zoom my friend
zoom
then i'm on oh yeah it's a lot i mean i
was saying to sistine before that we all
miss
just relationships and being around
people and hugging people yeah getting
to
make new relationships and since i
transferred to a new school it would be
nice to actually meet
more people that year but i also feel
like you're missing some of the best
years your senior year of high school
and your freshman year of college
those are some solid years yeah and
you're not getting either experience
i know i i really hope it's changing for
freshman year of college because
senior year already got taken away from
us but it's okay
it's okay i mean things happen but this
too shall pass
let's hope that she all schools start
opening up especially by
fall of 2021 so then scarlett can
actually go
into this well you look adorable in your
christmas pajamas yeah you look
beautiful
what do you what do you plan for the
rest of the day scarlett what do you
think i'm probably gonna make
gingerbread cookies
so fast again because i butchered the
last one she did it didn't taste very
good tastes like i was like molasses and
that was like one of the main
ingredients but whatever
whatever i don't even know if it's
christmas okay
well we love you thanks for coming on
scarlett why are you kicking me out
you can stay all right all right it's
the next segment
so we would love to end the show with
our favorite segment
our unsolicited advice i'm gonna give
you guys a quick little
instruction how to do it because
sometimes you know
y'all forget make sure you go to the
apple podcast page
go to ratings and review please give us
five stars and leave your question
in the ratings and review section okay
we read all of them and i honestly mean
that sophie and i were reading
all of the reviews yesterday and they
were so fun and i love them and it makes
my heart happy it honestly makes us
emotional because
sometimes we feel like you know what are
we doing this for but then we read your
comments and we're like okay it's so
worth it we do read your dm's too
and it's really sweet when we get like
these girls texting us or messaging us
i answer all of them yeah they're the
best you guys are so sweet so keep
motivating us because it really does
help you're kind of the reason why we're
still going at it
um so do you have a one that you're
going to this
is the first one okay what is the best
ice breaker for a first
time date and the worst and this is by
t-man
twelve one three nine seven what's up
t-man
all right the best ice breaker for a
first date
oh best ice breaker okay um i would say
do something
funny and sort of corny even though you
know sometimes a corny pickup line
it always makes someone laugh and yeah
you know obviously
if you give me if you say something like
you're the only 10 i see you're from
tennessee or
whatever the [ __ ] it is i would laugh
and be like you're such a goof you're
such an idiot and then right off the bat
i'm already smiling and boom
conversation starts you know what it is
for me is that the best icebreaker
doesn't have to be like a line
it can be just go into the date with
an abundance of energy and just be so
happy that you're there and you're
meeting a new person
even though this person may not have the
same exact
energy level as you just if you bring it
i
guarantee you their guards will be a
little bit more down they're going to be
like okay
yeah i can engage and be a little bit
more goofy and a piece of advice for
someone that
is a little bit nervous and they don't
know what to talk about or what to say
come into the date with a few questions
like ready to go in the back your head
so if you do feel like there's an
awkward silence you already know the
next thing to say
just something to you know um
i would say the worst from what i've
experienced at least the worst thing you
could probably say on a first date is
talking anything about your previous
relationships or your exes
that's a big red flag it's a big no no
girls don't like it i know for a fact
speaking as a female i'm sure guys don't
want to hear about them either just
pretend like you've never dated anyone
else
yeah just don't and especially for first
meeting this person you're walking into
the restaurant with them
just give them a nice compliment don't
be quiet until you get to the table
like bring up conversation be like it
was this restaurant farm so
glad you can be here with me tonight
dead air
especially right off the bat no hugging
like all that stuff like
even a handshake is kind of odd i just i
have to i'm gonna jump on that as well
yeah i love the compliment idea because
you don't realize how long someone
actually
takes to get rid of this date and it
almost makes all the worthwhile when a
guy says to you
oh you look really beautiful today and
for females too
compliment the guy they love it they
love it just as much as a woman does so
say
oh my gosh you look so handsome or i
love your shirt or whatever it'll make
his name
kind of crazy he's not not thinking
about it it's not very often a guy
on a date like first date will say like
oh you look great today or like do it
something unexpected makes our it takes
makes my night so
the hours that i spent thinking about
this one date that lasts
probably 30 minutes yeah it's worth it
it also shows
extreme confidence if you do that yes
okay next question sophia okay
so oops can i read it
yeah okay did you post it yeah oh they
weren't popping up online
oh yeah okay here we go sort of on the
same line
this person wrote what is your advice
for getting the woman of my dreams
specifically how do you find her
my man i
cannot help you with this one because i
have not
been in love yet you know how oh you
know i sit on that for a second
no no no you're young i think when
you're trying to find the person of your
dreams like
it's all about the things you put out
there that's what they're asking like
how do you do it
you have to attest this when you were
putting out a certain type of guy that
you wanted
in the first place and what you thought
you wanted you ended up getting those
guys
like all of them you got exactly the
check
box what you wanted yeah and
it didn't end up being the best so
really make sure you know what you want
and then put that energy out there tell
your friends say like this is the type
of girl i'm into this is the type of guy
i'm into
i like this personality this type of
look
but be open i think that's the biggest
lesson is to not just get your head
stuck on
one person that's a good point so say if
you're only into blondes that you're
only looking for a blonde female but you
might
fall in love with a redhead you never
know
so be open open heart i sometimes feel
like when you're looking too hard to
find
the one it'll never happen because then
you're just analyzing and nitpicking
every single thing about that other
person and then
you're gonna grow to hate them instead
of find love in their flaws
and that's you know going off of that i
don't love dating apps for that reason
because you think about you see your
type of guy on a dating app yeah
and i know i think they work i think
that they always like i've met
many of my friends have told me that
they met their person on dating apps and
things
but that's the problem with the dating
app is that you look at this person
online that is probably your type
by team physically and then you meet
them in person
and it's totally different but then you
skip a guy that maybe not
is your cup of tea physically you're
right it's very superficial
it's very superficial official okay so i
think
also that's i think then going full
circle
don't find your dream girl with their
exterior find your dream girl
what's on the inside if they're funny if
they're intelligent yeah someone that
really balances you out and
you want to actually hang out with for
24 hours a day well freaking set so
thank you well set all right yeah i can
do the
next one you go for it all right
it says one question i have is
is there something wrong with me if i
haven't had a boyfriend yet even though
i'm in college
everyone always says i'm the girl they
want to marry and that they don't want
to mess things up with how do i navigate
this as someone
who does want to be in a relationship
okay
the one part that stuck out to me a lot
was you said
everyone describes you as the one that
they want to marry
and you haven't been in a relationship
yet you're probably wondering like okay
well if i'm this perfect
marriage material girl why doesn't
anyone want to settle down with me
because
because they see that you're so special
and so good and mature
that they know that they're not ready to
handle all of that woman yet do you know
what i mean no i see what you're saying
and i agree with that i think
that the guys that you're probably
around are also immature
yeah and i think also when someone says
to you you're the girl i want to marry
it's kind of [ __ ] and it's probably
true you're probably a great girl that
is wifey material and i have girlfriends
that are like way more
ready for marriage than i would i'm ever
supposed to be
but the right guy will come up to you
and be like
i don't care if you're like the wife
material for me they're gonna want you
like a hundred percent like i think that
is just such a lame excuse for
yeah being afraid to be in a
relationship or whatever reason that you
don't want to stop well that's exactly
what it is
it's very in a relationship and yeah
they just say
if anything you should be happy that
this person is saying this to you
because you're probably saving yourself
a lot of heartache or a bad relationship
potentially
um yeah in the last episode also um and
i get it because
c9 both want to be relationships i'm not
looking for one
but i don't mind being in one right now
but
what we were talking about our last show
was that the fear of abandonment and
not being able to be okay with being
alone is really hard and
it is hard being alone and kind of
seeing all your friends find their
people
but really take that time for yourself
really
fall in love with the person you are on
the inside and then your person will
come yeah
and don't be don't feel bad for you that
you can't you know you haven't been in a
relationship because i
have been there especially this year
it's been a lot of
woe is me why am i single i know i'm a
good girl i know i'm a great girlfriend
why doesn't i want to be with me it's
not
us it's everyone else that's what i like
to tell them i also give system credit
though is that you have had your ups and
downs this year especially with dating
but you've really focused on now more
you and saying no to those people that
have treated you yes like the people
that have been like
oh i want you but not yet but give me
everything except the relationship part
and look what's happened i mean like we
really i know we keep hinting at things
that are coming up next year but
because we focus or because you focused
on yourself
yes way more than you would focus on a
guy girl you are
you are avoiding the most dangerous type
of guy
someone that isn't ready for commitment
but is sort of stringing you along and
saying you would be great
but he's essentially not great for me
yeah so
date yourself yeah date yourself look in
the mirror tell yourself you look
beautiful tonight
thank you for taking yourself to dinner
pour a glass of wine if you're of age
and enjoy it and enjoy yeah you're
you're good
you've got nothing with time what's that
suck um
it's like you got it so you got it so
you know what it is
no it says put your boss up
oh credit credit girl get at it
go get the
unlock potentially that you never know
you got it
you got it oh yeah yeah yeah okay
so that was it we started the show with
singing
um thank you guys so much for listening
once again to our christmas special
it's fun you know what hopefully this
all comes this is probably going to be
the most clipped kind of janky episode
but
i think that's 20 20 in another show
get with it end it as the year is and
then start it fresh
right off the top i promise the new year
episode will be so much smoother
because it's a fresh start right it'll
be better i promise but
thank you guys for listening to
us start this podcast in 2020 you know
it's been fun we're excited to continue
it in 2021
and thank you for coming along we love
you merry christmas